so signing on for a Marvel movie isn't
quite like signing on for any other
movie so what was the most surprising
thing about joining the world when
that's the MCU most surprising thing
most surprising thing I think what
surprised me surprising hmm this is why
you should have been drinking coffee
instead of the green because I'd be like
a big I love all this is coming out of
my ears that the superhero suits us so
no one tells you that they're there and
then once we you know you thought of
this no you should train for the suit
it's cuz it's like you snap back it what
snaps you back into this position and
you have to work against it but it's
quite it was quite a surprise I mean I
think you're spot on you've talked
you're taking this top spot there it's a
surprise I think I think secondly maybe
was how secret everything is cuz I've
been on I've been on other franchises
you know for other companies and felt
like I'd had my fair share of like don't
remove it all there's to reveal that
this was on all other level my children
were having to sign NDA's people to come
and visit me and cloaks cloaked with
hoods on to go from trailers to bathroom
or traitors to lunch it was it's intense
it's I mean they really protect it I'm
discussing yeah you know there's a huge
hunger for information but we were
discussing this yesterday it made you
because you're aware of that but when
when you're suddenly wearing the cloak
all day or or in hiding you suddenly
become a bit paranoid you think I know
there really are people out there trying
to get a photograph of it or are there
it's true who is everybody loves this
franchise so much and there are so many
good secrets that I can't wait for
everyone to experience in this one one
of my favorite parts about this movie
was the introduction of the Kree and I'm
just fascinated by Kree ideology which
obviously has it's got some good and not
so good in it so I was
wondering what part of the Kree beliefs
did did you to find yourself drawn to
most I have not been drawn to many of
them if I'm honest because there's it's
slightly imperialistic made me think
quite a lot I've been living in Rome for
the last few years and it reminded me of
a lot of the studies I've done there on
the Roman Empire you sort of very
physically driven also dominant
physically dominant and it's very tribal
and it's very you know awesome them
where the man is where superior and I
think you know that can be that can get
you so far but it's also very dangerous
and I you know it's not something I
could I mean I suppose the Admiral
thinks they have they're very they are
strong they are fearless they are
disciplined well so positive the race
above the individual that was one of the
things that kind of spoke to me I guess
more so than anything I think we told I
talked about that with Anna and Ryan for
we started and there's a kind of as well
as the kind of militaristic element
there's a kind of Buddhist thing as well
known through which is that yeah that
you are you the the whole comes for you
as an individual and there's something
very powerful in that you know and that
can be that can serve you well or it can
also be exploited I think absolutely how
about the supreme intelligence have you
two ever tried to envision who you might
see if you ever well there's a scene
that's actually not in the final cut of
this film
which i think is gonna be on me like
little textures so I'm not gonna reveal
but I actually shot a scene with my
characters superintelligence oh that's
kind of interesting and now the wheels
in my head are turning um before we have
to close this out I have a very
important question for you tell me
something so bizarre about yourselves
that a scroll couldn't even come up with
it that's a good one
sometimes I like to eat Marmite straight
from the jar do you know what Marmite do
you get my mommy Marmite Marmite no it's
a British beef reduction know it's you
either love it or you hate it
that is the eating peanut butter from
the jar maybe I'm missing out maybe no
I'm with you on that I know I don't like
that I like peanut butter okay mine is
by when I was four I painted my bike
gold and then I painted myself gold it
is the truth paid completely go ahead
because the bike looks so good I figured
like this so I played everything gold
and then we were at red with white paint
we're not yeah your pants clothes shoes
[Music]